oh
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
toute nouvelle émission consacrée à
l'union européenne dans l'europe et nous
nous avons choisi de nous intéresser
l'europe qui nous concerne directement
deux fois par mois nous allons donc nous
pencher sur ce que l'union européenne
change pour nous dans notre vie de tous
les jours
pour commencer nous allons évoquer
aujourd'hui l'un des programmes les plus
emblématiques de l'union européenne
c'est aussi l'une de ses réalisations
les plus concrètes il s'agit du
programme erasmus qui fête cette année
ses 20 ans d'existence
alors pour parler de ce programme nous
accueillons aujourd'hui odile quintin
bonjour bonjour vous êtes à la tête de
la direction générale de l'éducation et
de la culture à bruxelles est ici c'est
en quelque sorte l'équivalent d'un
ministère avec nous pour en parler
également sébastien mayer vous êtes
notre expert de bruxelles vous êtes en
quelque sorte le monsieur europe du
journal la croix
erasmus c'est le plus grand programme
d'échangé universitaire au monde la
possibilité pour tous les étudiants
européens de passer entre trois mois et
un an d'étude dans un autre pays
européen
aujourd'hui 31 pays participent au
programme en plus des vingt-sept sont
également concernés la norvège le
liechtenstein l'islande ou encore la
turquie
en vingt ans environ deux millions de
personnes ont connu l'expérience erasmus
je vous propose de regarder tout de
suite ce reportage tourné dans une
université parisienne
les cours ont déjà commencé à la
sorbonne mais les étudiants erasmus en
sont encore aux inscriptions avant de
rentrer en place ils doivent d'abord
faire face à une montagne et de
paperasserie au natal ya tout juste
arrivé de barcelone c'est le parcours du
combattant
on espérait 16 m'avait fait s'inscrire
c'est vraiment très difficile
la page web n'est pas clair du tout sur
les tableaux les horaires des cours ne
correspondent même pas à la réalité et
ça ça rend tout ça encore plus compliqué
être débrouillard c'est indispensable
pour les erasmus pas facile de financer
leur séjour
même s'il ne paye pas de frais
d'inscription dans le pays d'accueil les
aides financières varient du simple au
triple selon le pays d'origine
natalia ne sait toujours pas combien
elle va toucher en plus de la bourse
erasmus
alors pour payer son logement elle sera
serveuse dans un restaurant la ya un
problème parce que c'est vrai que bon la
bourse je crois qu'ils étaient 150 au
100 euros
c'est passé pour offert un séjour de six
mois d'un nom du bois de parfois des
britanniques ou d'espagnol qui viennent
avant on encore mois de juillet
travailler deux ou trois mois pour
financer leurs études pour faire
alba et axel ont connu les mêmes
difficultés il y a deux ans elle est
espagnole lui autrichien ils se sont
rencontrés pendant leurs années
d'erasmus et ont décidé de s'installer
en france pour travailler
axel fait une thèse de sociologie alba
cherche du travail dans la communication
aujourd'hui elle ne se sent plus
vraiment espagnol avait pas encore tout
à fait française et j'ai moins de
préjugés 1 belge 1 dès l'origine
différents aient dix ans que je ne me
sent nulle part je crois que ça c'est
être citoyen européen temps à prendre
plus facilement intégrés dans des
contextes tu connais pas auparavant ce
nous ça je crois que sa plainte du plan
profiter nord oscille entre vie
professionnelle
aujourd'hui près de 2 millions
d'étudiants cet atout en poche
d'ici cinq ans la commission européenne
espère atteindre le chiffre de 3
millions mais il faudra que les états
membres soutiennent activement cette
politique de mobilité
odile quintin on voit dans ce reportage
des étudiants deux ans après leur
expérience erasmus
qu'est ce que ce programme apporte aux
citoyens européens plus de 60% des
étudiants disent que ça les a aidés pour
trouver leur premier emploi et pour
trouver un emploi de qualité dont je
crois que ça c'est un élément positif
qu'est ce que ça apporte d'autres ça
apporte la connaissance de l'autre la
connaissance d'un autre système
l'immersion dans un autre monde culturel
et là aussi si vous interrogez les
employeurs s'est pas seulement la
connaissance linguistique ou ou
techniques qui seront acquis pendant
pendant les races mais c'est aussi cette
ouverture sur sur l'autre
il ajoute qu'il ya beaucoup d'étudiants
erasmus qui se marie en termes de
citoyenneté européenne je crois que
c'est aussi un âne est tous importants
alors dans certains pays qui connaissent
erasmus depuis vingt ans la mobilité a
tendance à s'essouffler comment est-ce
que vous l'expliquer mais je pense que
des situations un peu différente suivant
suivant les pays
souffle notamment au royaume-uni et en
irlande il ya de toute évidence un poème
de connaissances linguistiques
il ya aussi dans ces pays énormément des
changes avec les pays tiers notamment
avec les états unis
par contre dans certains pays comme
l'espagne ou comme l'allemagne que
certaines mesures comme la france elle
continue à augmenter de manière
significative
il ya aussi des décisions par certains
pays par rapport à la mobilité bon
l'espagne a décidé d'augmenter 800% son
budget de mobilité pour compléter
notamment pour preuve les terrasses plus
il est certain que ça a un effet massif
sur le nombre d'étudiants erasmus
elle vous parler de budget le budget
annuel d'erasmus est d'environ 400
millions d'euros
sébastien manière vous avez une vue
d'ensemble des différents programmes
européens est ce que ce budget à la
hauteur du programme erasmus c'est vrai
que c'était un budget certaines
implantations mais si on regarde sur un
budget européen annuel
allez comparer jusqu'à la politique
agricole commune qui jusque dans les 45
milliards d'euros mais c'est vrai qu'il
ya ce décalage entre la popularité
d'erasmus et puis finalement la modestie
on peut bien dire relative du de ce
budget dans dans l'ensemble du budget
européen
alors justement vous vous demandez ce
que par rapport aux ambitions que vous
avez notamment à cet avenir où on veut
aller jusqu'à 3 millions d'étudiants
erasmus à l'horizon 2013 c'est 4
millions c'est encore un très
insuffisant notamment rappelé que la
brouille de la commission avait proposé
nettement plus donc ça ça a été une
décision générale mais que quand même le
budget a augmenté de près de 40% ce qui
est quand même pas négligeable
je crois que la réponse dans le cadre
des perspectives financières actuelles
qui ne vont pas bouger
c'est le complément pas soit les états
membres du site est le cas l'espagne sur
les entreprises
donc il va falloir reprises qu'il ya des
risques
il ya des entreprises qui sont
intéressés d'ailleurs erasmus sa nouvel
élément du programme depuis cette année
développe énormément le partenariat
entre universités et entreprises qui est
quelque chose que que nous poussons
beaucoup et où d'un pays à l'autre les
aides varient du simple au triple on a
pu le voir dans ce reportage comment
faire pour harmoniser l'ensemble du
système pour démocratiser le système je
pense pas qu'on va harmoniser parce que
c'est pas un domaine d'harmonisation
mais par contre on peut faire des
échanges de bonnes pratiques
quand vous raconter à tout le monde que
l'espagne augmentent de 8 100 % ça fait
un petit peu stimulant pour pour les
pays qui sont beaucoup plus modestes et
modérée donc c'est par cette
transparence de ce qui se passe dans les
différents payés par les changes de
bonnes pratiques qu'on va essayer de
faire bouger les choses
j'ai entendu l'autre jour dans un débat
que j'ai eu avec elle même pécresse
annoncé qu'elle augmentait de manière
significative à partir de l'année
prochaine
le complément erasmus je crois que c'est
une décision qui va dans le bon sens
quel souffle peut donner la présidence
française au programme erasmus qu'est ce
qui est prévu je crois que la présidence
française peut se situer dans le
prolongement de ce que c'est de faire en
ce moment la présidence portugaise c'est
à dire la démocratisation d'erasmus vous
pouvez essayer de faire une approche de
la mobilité des jeunes basé sur
l'excellente acte hier asmus sur
d'autres sujets d'ailleurs le parlement
européen est en train de voter des
actions pilotes sur un erasmus de la
culture
sur en erasmus des apprentis sur un
erasmus des jeunes fonctionnel on peut
essayer de bâtir sur erasmus pour
d'abord l'optimiser ça c'est en
particulier la coopération avec avec les
différents pays et avec les entreprises
et puis pour s'inspirer d'erasmus pour
d'autres pour d'autres domaines et puis
on peut toujours rêver aux futures
perspectives financières alors dans le
reportage que que l'on a vu deux
étudiants erasmus ont décidé de
s'installer en france ils sont
directement concernés par cette question
de la mobilité
ils ont une question à vous poser je
reste tout de suite de l'écouter
maxisciences com hambourg faire on sent
que le gens qui font ce fonds une année
erasmus pour rester après ce jeu de
séjour ça devient encore plus
profondément dans le pays d'accueil la
fois quelque chose il ya une chose qui
existe déjà c'est les partenariats
erasmus entreprises
les entreprises peuvent développer les
partenariats avec les universités où il
ya des étudiants erasmus pour un
placement des étudiants c'est bien d'un
placement de stage le sap est un
placement à plus longue durée dont ça
fonctionne c'est certainement ça
fonctionnait et on est en train de
sélectionner les projets dans ce
contexte
donc ça c'est une une deuxième chose qui
est lié à ce que nous faisons sur le
marché du travail j'étais responsable de
l'emploi avant de l'être de l'éducation
et de la culture
c'est le res eurest qui est la base de
données européenne sur les offres
d'emploi donc un étudiant qui a fait un
erasmus en france comme les deux
étudiants combien de fois va regarder la
base de données de l'emploi en france et
il a toute la transparence sur des
offres qui peuvent correspondre à ces
qualifications et reveillère qui sera
embauchée mais au moins il le saura il
saura quelle entreprise x à tel endroit
qu'ils aient besoin de quelqu'un qui a
un profil analogue est donc à la fois
par le biais du programme erasmus sûr
tant que tel et par le lien avec cette
base de données très importantes reste
est très très très visité sur l'emploi
il peut avoir un accès aux emplois dans
le pays où il a étudié odile quintin je
vous remercie
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
également à sébastien maillard notre
expert de bruxelles et on se retrouve
dans deux semaines pour un non
numéro de l'europe et nous à très
bientôt